mosey nation a lot of people ask how do
you guys get so much stuff done how does
how do the companies move forward with
such speed um and for those who don't
know my name is alex hormozy we own
acquisition.com our portfolio does about
85 million a year and i have nothing to
sell you which is why i have no coaches
i have no courses and i have no
masterminds i give you all this stuff
because i just want you to not be broke
and a lot of people are and so i want
you to be one of them all right and so
this video is a video that was i
released in a group a very long time ago
and it's one of the top ranked videos in
that group out of 300 videos and it was
how we tactically execute on speed so
speed is king is one of the core tenants
of our companies actually turning that
concept of speed into something that
everyone can execute on is one of the
key things that moves you forward
towards your goals faster all right and
it's not what a lot of people think it's
not about being impatient it's not a lot
not about trying to to get a hundred
things done but it's about knowing how
to get the things done that matter a and
then b how do we get these short tasks
done in a way that actually moves teams
forward rather than individuals all
right so i think you'll enjoy the video
it was ranked one of the top ones and
i'll see you on the other side mosey
nation love you
good morning everyone hope you guys are
having a fantastic friday um today i
wanted to uh talk about something that
um has been it's been on my doctor for a
while but today felt like the right day
i'm calling this
[ __ ] end of week what i mean by that is
one of the things that i've seen across
the board when we're talking to
entrepreneurs and you know the the gym
owner community that we have is that the
one trait i see over and over again that
is clear to the people who are are
winners right the top one percent i'm
not talking top 10
but the top one percent is the speed
with which they execute after making a
decision one of the definitions that
like we talk about in the community is
that definition of power as i understand
it is
the gap between thoughts becoming
reality and so if you thought about an
omnipotent being right something someone
who has unlimited power as they think
that thing would be right and so if you
were to believe in a creator of some
sort then you might think as that
creator thought the universe became
right and so if you think that as like
the ultimate scale of power then the
closer we can get to that the more
powerful we become the more potent we
are as entrepreneurs and so i see this
so many times that it's it's not even
it's not even uh oh like this is
associated with success like this is
what creates success because the gap
between where you decide something is a
good idea and when it actually occurs is
the loop with which you can improve your
business and so it's a lot like
i can't remember what the saying was but
it's not like how old the car is but how
many miles are on it what i mean by that
is like we're young right but there's
been a lot of a lot of iterations that
have happened from
you know when the business first started
when i started my first gym until now
and i think the key to that is the speed
of the ooda loop and that's that's just
like a military term like observe orient
decide act and it's just the loop with
which that you can basically see what's
going on make a decision act on it and
then do that whole loop again right
because the faster you can pivot and
iterate the more responsive you are as
an entrepreneur the faster you can take
advantage of opportunities the faster
you can find out what failures are then
move on i want to talk about this within
the context of running a team and
employees and then also within yourself
and so
from running your team right one of the
things that you know
once once you're moving out of you doing
things all the time there's how do i get
other people to do things and so that's
why i called this like [ __ ] end of week
right is that
i one of the things one of my biggest
pet peeves is like yeah i can get to
that by end of week i'm like why don't
you just get it to me in an hour because
that's how long it takes and then all of
a sudden it's like oh it's like well i
have a meeting right then it's like is
it more important than this no okay well
then do it like if you think about how
you can run an organization like that if
you can get things done end of day right
rather than end of week you were
literally speeding up the organization
7x think about that and so when you're
thinking about deadlines and you're
thinking about expectations you as the
owner can set the x you set the cadence
if people say hey can we do this and
then you're like cool let's start right
now
you set the tone for how the
organization's going to move how quickly
it's going to orient how quickly
thoughts become reality and ultimately
how powerful your organization will
become because of the speed right and
speed isn't doing things fast it's
basically just not being distracted by
other [ __ ] that doesn't matter it's
being able to prioritize and most people
a lot of the times aren't doing
something that's high priority right a
lot of times they're just doing nothing
if you can speed up that loop and
force and and put apply pressure to your
team to not do things by end of week or
even end of day it's like it's 10 a.m
can you get this done by noon
uh okay and then you can have that loop
happen three times within a day rather
than it taking three weeks right because
you set that cadence from the beginning
and then things get done faster so i've
been reading some really interesting
books lately you know and i referred
them out to um a handful of entrepreneur
friends that i have that are all doing
five five to 15 million kind of in that
range and what was amazing to me is that
every single one of them
read the book immediately
sent me back their notes and what they
were going to do with it and at like and
basically were asking feedback on on the
angle that they were going to take with
it what's fascinating to me is that if
you look at if you look at lower level
entrepreneurs
they and i'm not saying in a negative
way i'm just saying in terms of just
objective revenue like just they haven't
achieved as much the delay between being
able to gain information and act is so
much longer and that's why they how
where they want to be it's kind of the
same degree of people who are like who
pay for our program and haven't gone
through the poor yet i'm like what do
you do right like what priority like
what what education do you have that is
not relevant to your business like
you're reading a motivational blog right
now when
you have to translate that motivation
into a thought that you're then going to
quote test and then you have to see how
that test works and then maybe it
improves something rather than just
following the playbook that has already
been tested and has already like the the
tree has been shook right
and so
if you look at like joey for example who
by by all definitions his gym is the is
the number one gym within gym launch
right he had already finished everything
in legacy by week eight his first eight
weeks he'd already implemented every
single system in legacy and so it's not
like it's not like he has more hours in
the day right it's not like his business
is different it's just that his level of
efficacy in execution was so high
because it didn't allow himself to get
distracted by things and the moment he
has something he needs to execute it's
creates this itch inside of him that he
cannot he can't move
forward without executing this so that
the relief comes and if you can start to
foster that type of behavior in yourself
in those attitudes about execution you
will grow faster and you will become
more powerful as an entrepreneur right
if you think about your competition who
would you fear right the competitor who
sees what you're doing
can immediately execute implement and
improve on it at a faster loop than you
can even understand what's going on
right and that's where speed of first to
market and things like that don't matter
as much because if an ex if a competitor
can execute an out ooda loop right can
can speed that loop up faster they can
iterate improve on it faster than you
can and then you have no chance to catch
up and so if you're looking at your
business
look at it from a context of speed of
how long does it take us to improve
things how long from understanding that
our churn is high to executing the five
horsemen how long did that take we knew
what the problem was how long did it
take for us to do and if you can if you
can if you can get real with yourself
about how many actual hours it will take
to do something and then you look at
your week and you think okay what am i
doing today that is more important than
this and where can i put these two hours
and start with the moment that you make
the decision and then all of a sudden
you'll be getting things done that day
that afternoon rather than end of week
end of month we purposely delay these
things because we just procrastinate for
no reason when the the problem will not
go away right and so
that is why within gym launch speed is
king is one of the core tenants of the
business because you have to and the
tone has to start with you as the
entrepreneur like you have to apply that
pressure you have to say [ __ ] end of
week why like what are you doing today
that's more important than this right
what are you doing in the next two hours
that's more important than this tell me
right and a lot of times you'll get the
answer like well i guess i can do it now
it's like yeah then let's do it now
let's get it done right and that
small change
can 7x right if you even going from end
of week to end of day
can 7x how quickly your business grows
because the solutions that you need to
implement to solve the problems and
break through the bottlenecks happen
today not in a week not in a month and
then the reaction to the next thing that
breaks the next bottleneck in the
business happens not in a week not in a
month but in a day and then that's how
quickly you can pivot from where you are
to where you want to go because it's not
one big thing it's a million small turns
that will get you there anyways i hope i
hope anyone you know somebody found
value in this if you have an employee or
you're managing your team and you want
to implement new things
start with today right start with end of
day not end of week start with end of
the next two hours and then work
backwards from there and then apply
pressure and and push back on excuses
for why something else why something
can't be done ask for why why do you
think this thing that you're going to do
is more important than this and i want a
real answer right and if they can't give
you a real answer then it means that i
need to help you prioritize and that's
fine but this is now going to be your
priority because this is what drives
revenue this is what drives retention
this is what's going to drive the
business look at your schedule identify
the bottlenecks you have
and then start doing them now not in
tomorrow not in a week not in a month
because there's no point it's just the
speed with which you can close the gap
between your thoughts and your decisions
and the reality that you create in front
of you will dictate how powerful you are
as an entrepreneur and even as a human
being so anyways have an amazing day
have a fantastic friday for my gym lords
i will see you guys on the call later
today otherwise keep being awesome tag
like comment all that jazz um lots of
love all right